Rodney is with us Rodney is in New York
hi Rodney how can Kenan me help you hi
Dave can't help your family they're
doing well they are thank you thank you
everybody's good my question for you is
I have some extended family who have
fallen on hard times they've been laid
off unfortunately and they've asked me
for a loan and to be quite frank with
you I'm just seeing how they spend money
I do not believe that I will be paid
back I don't think they have the
discipline you know to manage it well
but I also don't think this is the time
to be like hey guys you should manage
your budget better but I really don't
feel comfortable giving them this one so
how do you how much knowledge is it key
alone they're asking for uh 15 $15,000
yes and how what is your situation is
that an easy number for you or you have
to strain to do that I'm in baby steps
for so that would come out of the B be
what I guess three to six months yeah
this is not an emergency
so what do they need $15,000 for they
they said that they managed to get
creditors to give them a temporary
reprieve on some of their car notes they
have some credit cards down but they
don't think that their jobs are going to
come back before the temporary you know
suppression of all the all the fees and
the interest and whatnot so and then
they also don't have any savings and
they have kids so you know they're
they're they're sort of and how are they
near you in proximity I mean can you sit
down with a matted kitchen table
geographically yeah all right well if it
was my family here's what I would do
okay
I do not want to be an enabler I do not
want to give a drunk a drink which was
your concern in the way you stated your
question if you have I don't think you
have fifteen thousand dollars to loan in
buddy or give anybody right now either
because this is not an emergency for
your family to give them $15,000 so i if
i sat down at their kitchen table it
would probably result in two or three
things that would be very uncomfortable
for them occurring I might give them
three or four thousand dollars to meet
some absolute horrible things like mood
or lights and on the condition that they
attend the 14-day free trial for a
Financial Peace University and take
every class in the next 14 days and on
the condition that they sell both of
their cars and on the condition that
they put together a budget and show it
to me every week for the next two months
and on the canoe and they're not gonna
want to do any of that and you're not
gonna loan them any money as a result
use this as a way that help them get on
track yeah I mean here's the thing I'll
help you help you but I'm not going to
stimulate your stupidity by giving you
fifteen thousand dollars so you can act
like that you hadn't been stupid so
you're gonna sell both these cars
because you shouldn't have bought them
in the first place you're gonna get you
a couple of hoop these oh and then
you're gonna get on King Coleman site
and you're gonna get like three of these
part-time jobs that are popping up
everywhere
everybody's hiring in certain sectors
right now you don't have to sit at home
again what could they do yeah I mean
they thing to be delivering things they
need to be stocking shelves they need to
be in warehouses they're going there you
know they're doing everything got to do
you got Target Walmart Amazon CVS
Walgreens I'm just naming a few thing go
to my Instagram account we have
everything little places hiring
everything very tiring I think to your
point Dave you're right they gotta have
to do a lot of things with evidence and
I don't think they're gonna do it by the
way so that I would if I if I could sit
down with them and I could wave a wand
over their little brain and change it
and say the cars are gone you're getting
all these part-time jobs and get some
income in I'll give you $3,000 to cover
these one or two things you're gonna be
on a budget and you're going through
this class because you're gonna change
your life
gonna be happy you did and this is a
gift it's not alone I don't loan people
money